an investigation into a deadly
fraternity boxing match points to a
failure by metro police and a lack of
cooperation from the other boxer this is
a story our i-team first broke thank you
for joining us i'm brian loftis i'm
vanessa murphy 8 news now is the first
to obtain a report with some shocking
findings which the nevada state athletic
commission will address tomorrow morning
from the planning to the event to the
aftermath this 158-page report from the
nevada attorney general's office points
to numerous failures surrounding this
deadly fraternity boxing match in
november
twenty-year-old nathan valencia seen
here in the red headgear took fatal
blows to the head he collapsed moments
after the fight i told him you're going
to be ok like just keep pushing through
it and i thought he was going to be ok
danielle corona is one of the more than
dozen interviewed by investigators their
three key findings not all fighters were
students which led to confusion over
what agency could regulate the fight
metro police failed to investigate
whether foul play was involved the
report states the department only looked
into whether the venue had a business
license while there was a missed
opportunity to learn whether valencia's
opponent was on drugs or tampered with
his hand wraps or gloves by packing them
as suggested by several witnesses and
metro's public statements eliminated any
possibility for future prosecution it
was just fighting like there was no like
boxing involved of it david cruz shot
this video mentioned in the report where
an unlicensed referee is seen drinking
what appears to be alcohol one witness
stated they were offered cocaine at the
event paramedics said when they arrived
two groups they encountered appear to be
intoxicated i think there is somebody to
blame here and i think it's
the fraternity for
organizing a poor event and
not ensuring the safety of
their fighters usa boxing's executive
director told investigators the kappa
sigma fraternity was repeatedly warned
about the danger of holding events like
this one investigators determined
numerous protocols weren't followed no
pre-fight weigh-in or medical physical
no certified ref or judges no doctor at
ringside and no ambulance on standby no
inspection of hand wraps gloves or
headgear investigators say they examined
gear used at the event except for
valencia's opponents witnesses said
emanuel ailman's hands were wrapped long
before the fight his attorney sean
claggett confirmed to the i-team he told
aleman not to speak with investigators
while investigators say even claggett
didn't return their calls according to
the report a unlv detective said he
spoke with illman's stepfather who
denied any tampering with the gloves or
hand wraps he called the punches thrown
girl swings and stated sometimes people
die that's why nathan valencia's loved
ones have been in mourning
it's tough it's really tough this
because he just he was a great guy
emmanuel ailman's attorneys say he was
not under the influence of an illicit
substance during the fight and he did
not pack his gloves they say they told
him not to speak with investigators
because of the investigator's reliance
on misrepresentation and metro police
just sent me a statement disputing the
findings of the attorney general's
office you can find the full statements
at eight newsnow dot com